according to a CNN SSRS poll DeSantis is
now at top of the Republican primary
field 39 to Trump's 37 so essentially
tied Haley is at seven Pence is at six
Tim Scott's at two so new news at two
Junkin is even in the poll he's at one
percent it remains anybody's race the
national polls don't really matter when
it comes to presidential primaries
because the primaries happen state by
state so what matters is who's a lady in
Iowa who's leading in New Hampshire
who's leading in South Carolina who's
leading in Florida because as momentum
builds that's how you're going to see
the real hierarchy of candidates begin
to shape up it won't happen for a while
but according to another poll more than
one-third of Biden voters do not want
him to run again and so you can expect
more Republican candidates